ok let's go 2 3 1 3 I think we tried 3 1
3 before and we heard nothing so caller
from 3 1 3 if you can hear me this time
please tell us who you are and where
you're calling from uh my name is Ian
Chobani and I'm calling from Detroit
Michigan okay what's up yeah I just
wanted to say I'm a libertarian and I
believe the solution to getting money
and lobbyists out of government is to
reduce the overall federal budget the
crop which the corporation's are trying
to get a piece of if the budget gets
considerably reduced then the government
will have less power to do handouts to
Wall Street for example or tax cuts and
subsidies for big corporations so I'm
asking you what what is your take on how
to get that stuff out of government
while still having a large federal
budget okay so let's accept is right now
the reason that there's such an interest
in having lobbyists and being involved
with government is that government has
such a large budget they control tons of
contracts for corporations so there's an
incentive to lobby government to give
out these contracts so you're suggesting
if we shrink the amount that government
is doing it disincentivizes lobbying and
money in politics is that right okay
I mean am I am i stating your position
correctly no but like hella yeah okay
well we lost them
it was an interesting question I was
just Pat trying to establish a common
ground of what the assertion was because
my next question would have been and
I'll just ask it now because so people
know where I was thinking I would have
said what aspects of what do you want to
take away from being under the purview
of government and then the next question
would be what would be the impact of
taking that away from government and
giving it directly to private industry
because I think that's where we would
come up with a problem right and that's
where you get completely corporate
controlled health insurance I think
we're gonna get somewhere I don't know
where that place would be yeah I guess
we'll never know I guess we'll never
know but I like that call it was it was
going in a direction I felt it was good
and then we just lost lost connection
okay let's take a break and we will be
with plenty more right after this